we're thrilled to have Paul here today
you know history is always a mess in the
history of spirits and drinking is
particularly hard to follow and and full
of unreliable things when the way long
now thinks about about futurism and
history is all on one kind of continuum
of if we look at predicting and thinking
about the future
if we're and and rigorously looking at
the past are together but actually
paying attention in the moment to what's
going on today
is the route to both good futurism and
good histories and paul has been paying
attention to spirits and cocktails in
this country in a way more seriously one
of the first ones to really take
seriously what was happening so again
he's going to be taking us through that
continuum on spirits in cocktail into
the future and from the past so big
round of applause for our guys tonight
thank you
before I get started I have a brief
confession to make I don't actually have
a crystal ball despite the name of the
session cut the [ __ ] guild crystal ball
you know I toyed around with the idea of
actually like purchasing one online go
on Amazon or something and bring on
bring in one just for visual aid but the
consumer reviews on those things are
terrible they're notoriously unreliable
so I decided to save the cash and and
bring it down here and spin it at the
bar as Michael said I've been doing this
for a while I started writing about
cocktails professionally about ten years
ago and had been dabbling with it
personally for several years before that
really as the cocktail Renaissance or
cocktail revolution or whatever you want
to call it was just starting to pick up
steam and just starting to get some
energy behind it and so it seems like a
long time to me and I'm one of those
people who really gets hooked on I can
have milestones and markers and looking
back you know my god what have I done
with the last 10 years of my life but
when you think about it you know 10
years is just that merest little
heartbeat of a firefly
and the great scheme of things and even
in the great scheme of cocktails which
as a history that doesn't go back nearly
as far as I assume an evolution even
though you know I'm sure that there are
some of their prehistoric ancestors who
badly needed a drink but it does have a
very long history and we're at only a
certain milestone in that history we
live at a time when cocktail creativity
and cocktail innovation is at a
particularly vivid point but we're only
at one point on that timeline so when
we're talking about coming down here and
doing this we thought it would be fun to
play around with the idea of looking at
that long arc of cocktail history and
where what's come before us what kind of
signs and tips does it give us for
what's coming ahead and what does it
look like they were gonna be drinking
let's say a hundred years from now
what's the cocktail in your class going
to look like is it going to be something
you know kind of like the Jetsons of
cocktails you know we're looking for
your flying car of cocktails is it going
to be Soylent Green
or is it going to be something that's
very much related not too dissimilar
from why you have in your glass right
now so we're gonna kind of tease those
threads out here for a little bit now of
course you've got to start at the
beginning for any story and the
beginning of the cocktail really starts
several hundred years ago before the
calculate even developed the primordial
soup of the cocktail was served in the
punch bowl the punch bowl was that
vessel through which for centuries
during the Age of Exploration people
would spend their time and days and and
and relaxing with each other and
socializing with each other with each
other over the mixtures that they're
putting in the punch bowl the punch bowl
was that formative place where we worked
through some of the rough forms that
would later evolved into the cocktail we
sir we found certain things that would
resonate later on for example that
brandy really loves to be put together
with oranges and with sugar or that rum
really benefits from being put together
with limes and some of those lessons
were first learned in the punch bowl
during the during that Age of
Exploration and leading up to the
settlement of the new world and during
those first decades of the settlement of
the new world but when you look at the
paleoanthropology of the cocktail the
cocktail marked a distinct step in the
evolution of how we drink not just in
terms of what we actually put into a
glass and the ingredients that go into
the glass and the way that we prepare
that but it marked a very significant
step in the way that we think about
ourselves the way we think about her
culture and the way that we live our
lives fittingly while the punch bowl was
the ruler of the drinks world for
centuries that was largely at a time
when the world was being determined by
primarily by European powers the
cocktail is very much at home in the New
World and we're and it fits very much in
in the heart of our of our character and
of the new worlds approach it was pretty
fertile terrain for the development of
the cocktail so before we get into some
of the particulars of what the
early cocktails look like than the way
that they kind of marked those
evolutionary steps and set us up for it
for what we've come it's helpful to look
at a few patterns what were a few things
that existed in the new world that made
this fertile terrain for that and that
have driven the path of the cocktail to
the point where we are now and they give
us some clues for where we may be going
in the future first off of course you
had cultural shifts you know at the time
that the Republic was born you had the
stirrings of the Industrial Revolution
you had people who are uprooted and
coming to a new place and starting new
enterprises and building new cities and
you know going out and and manifesting
their destiny and exploring this this
new country it meant reducing the amount
of leisure time the time there was
typically spent four hours around a
Punchbowl playing cards playing games
other kinds of sporting endeavors
now we filled that role with much
tighter timeframes a drink was something
that you lingered over for a matter of
minutes or their than a matter of hours
and if it very much in character with
that faster tighter more efficient mode
that the United States was suggesting
was soon after the birth of the Republic
you also had that that the melting pot
idea of the Americas where the old world
was tradition balance your father was a
pig farmer his father is pig farmer
before him and so on back several
generations of pig farmers from your
family and so was your future as well
but if you're picked up uprooted from
that pig farm in Germany and placed in
the New World you're placed in New York
or Boston all of a sudden you see a
future that is possibly devoid of
fiction and so some of those old
patterns some of those old traditions
that you've been down to no longer apply
to you so some of those patterns
factored into not only the way that we
live our everyday lives and the way that
we pursue our careers our businesses but
also in the way that we drank we were
free to develop our own traditions your
big firmer father may have had an ale
every day at lunch and an ale every day
at dinner and half a dozen ales in the
evening as did your grandfather and
great-grandfather and generations before
that you may enjoy ill nothing against
al but in your new life in the new world
you might feel like a whiskey you might
you are not constrained by the way that
your family had always done things over
the pattern of generations we also you
also saw that mixture the melting pot
mixture in the United States where all
of a sudden you could go into
establishment and you would have Dutch
gen up against French brandy or whiskey
from Pennsylvania or from Maryland or
maybe there's a peach brandy from
Georgia or some Applejack from New
Jersey and all of these things appearing
together again in a way that was
relatively unfamiliar or have not been
widespread in the old world in the
centuries before it so basically the old
rules were off and every everything was
possible at the beginning of the 19th
century also setting the stage for the
development of the cocktail and the
growth of the cocktail over the course
of the 19th century were technological
changes the evolution of distillation
itself and at the end of the 18th
century there I've seen one estimate
where there were around 400 distilleries
in the state of New Jersey alone a lot
of these were very small-scale farm
distilleries very small capacity where
you would distill your apple crop and
maybe that of your neighbors and that
was a very common farm practice where
for generations and generations at the
beginning of the 19th century death
started to change round about that time
owing to excise taxes owing to eventual
consolidation of the industry and we saw
this play out over the course of the
19th century of that huge number of
distilleries suddenly plummet to a
smaller number over the course of the
century and become much more
concentrated and much more focused this
was also kind of coinciding with the
technological developments in
distillation the coffee still or the
continuous path or the continuous column
still was patented in 1830 this was you
know again one of the significant
technological leaps away from the
traditional pot still that was you know
that could make lovely lovely spirits
but was relatively slow relatively in a
fish
to operate now you could operate you can
make the spirits on a much larger scale
much faster and really make it on an
industrial level and that was kind of
one of those ticks - you know what this
start changing the gears and
accelerating the whole process of the
the evolution of the cocktail and that
wasn't the only technology of course
that was coming into play when the new
world was first settled a lot of the
spirits you know you drank locavore not
by choice but because you really had no
other you really had nothing else
available if you didn't feel like
drinking pumpkin beer and pumpkins were
the only thing they grew in your area
then you were going dry you know we did
have some imports from Europe but
typically those were for the wealthier
who could who could afford French wines
or French Brandy's for the most part
people were drinking local earlier early
in the 19th century and accelerating
with the introduction of things like the
Transcontinental Railroad and the
introduction of the steamship we started
to see those spirits along with every
other sort of manufactured item
traveling around the country moving from
one place to another including bringing
more things over from Europe and them
being distributed further across the
country then just simply in the seaports
where they were so then you was not
unusual to find in the mid 19th century
to go to a saloon and say Colorado or in
the gold digs in Nevada
and find an Italian liqueur or to find a
Dutch gin in that bar it was something
that was not only considered essential
to a saloon but it was relatively
available it was it was possible to
access these things so in that way the
technology was was helping spread these
ingredients around and along with the
knowledge of what to use with them along
with this both technological
technologically driven as well as other
factors of economics and culture we had
evolution of spirits themselves they gin
for example Jen you know originated in
the Netherlands and in Belgium sometimes
you know as early as the third
century no later than the sixteenth
century the English quite literally went
crazy for the stuff and you know the gin
craze led to massive not only economic
but also political tumult in England as
well as the the appropriation of the
style for their own spirits so he saw
the development from the class a kind of
malty rich yen over Dutch style gins
along the the timeline into the 19th
century with the rise of sweeter
somewhat drier old Tom Jen's and then
ultimately with things like Plymouth Jen
and London Dry also with liquid whiskey
you know whisky was one of those stories
again of you know working locally taking
the technology from making a
traditionally barley based distillate in
Scotland and Ireland and using the
grains that you had available which in
the new world were things like rye or
corn and then of course you know the
whiskey as they were making it then
wasn't necessarily similar to the
whiskey that we think of it now or the
whiskey that you taste now in addition
to the changes in distillation
technology we had changes in maturation
were you actually aging in oak barrels
were they toasted oak barrels or they
used oak barrels with a charred oak
barrels or there are no oak barrels at
all also was there anything added to the
whiskey it wasn't until really the turn
of the 20th century that we really got
on top of the additives going into
whiskey sometimes additives going into
whiskey in the 19th century could be
things fairly innocently like maybe you
would put tea or prunes in there to make
a little bit darker color give a little
bit richer flavor or it could be a
little bit more suspect like putting a
little spike of kerosene in there to
give a little angle or we're putting
tobacco in again for it for the same
kind of coloration aspect but there
would also kind of give you a little
edge when you drank it ultimately by the
turn of the 20th century that was one of
those marking points and the evolution
of that that again dictated what was
going into our glasses and rum as well I
mean rum for much of its history was
fairly rough stuff you know rums one of
rums first
my guess was kill devil which tells you
pretty much everything you need to know
about the quality of it and the
experience of drinking it and it really
wasn't until the late 19th early 20th
century through the column still and the
coffee still finally making its way to
the Caribbean and really being embraced
that you saw a rum starting to clean up
and become refined and become much more
in line with the rums that we think um
that we experience today what were the
things that we didn't really see in the
United States in the 19th century
well vodka was one for various cultural
reasons
it just wasn't prevalent here yet you
just don't really find any kind of much
interaction with it nor with tequila I
mean on occasion you would find some
reference to tequila but it was usually
in very negative terms and so it was
something that you just never really saw
in the United States that would
eventually change we're gonna come to
that a little bit but I wanted to put
all this out there because this was the
context in which the cocktail involves
this was the context in which the
cocktail was first created came out of
the punch bowl crawled up on the shore
and began its process of evolution
through the 19th century and really
hitting a full head of steam as it
approached the 20th century so I should
have put up but that up there earlier if
you want to tweet about this or
Instagram that's where to find this but
if you want to look at the Homo erectus
of the bar you need to look at the basic
cocktail the brandy cocktail this this
recipe is actually the photograph I took
was from in 1887 books used so you've
already seen it developed a certain
degree when the cocktail first entered
circulation nearly a hundred years
before or so a little over 80 years
before it was simply spirits pick your
pick your spirit whiskey brandy Jen what
have you some sugar some bitters and
some water occasionally though we're
increasingly the waters in the form of
ice by 1887 they'd reached up a little
bit with the addition Carissa and also
in eighteen by 1887 you came up with
always considered the improved cocktail
what maiden approved putting more stuff
in it basically it's but the the decor
elements to look out here is this
is almost entirely spirits I mean when
it says a wine glass of brandy that's
two ounces everything else is in terms
of dashes drips and drabs so the spirit
is basically the outfit that the
cocktail is wearing and the curse out
the bitters the gum syrup our
accessories
it's a pinkie ring it's it's a
handkerchief it's just little things
that are dangling off of the spirit to
kind of soothe Oh smooth over some of
the rough edges maybe point up a couple
of aspects of flavor and make a little
bit more delightful all the way around
so this was you know the early stages
that the early signs of evolution two
things happens also about this time
starting mating 50s 1860s and leading up
into the 1870s we're really sorry to
pick up steam the first was citrus juice
this was not unusual this is reaching
directly back into the punchbowl and
pulling out one of boozes best friends
you take whiskey match it with lemon
wonderful brandy mix it with lemon
wonderful rum lime wonderful it's again
it soothes over some of those rough
edges it takes down the auch the alcohol
percentage just a tad so it makes it a
little bit more agreeable a little bit
more approachable and then you've got a
put sugar in the mix in some form
whether it's directly as sugar or as a
liqueur or as a fruit syrup or pick some
other application and over all that it's
just a wonderful experience to come
around the second important element and
I think that's probably even more
important was the introduction of
vermouth now vermouth of course had been
around for four centuries it just had
not really been fully appropriated into
cocktails until really 1870s 1880s when
you start saw it starting to happen
vigorously this recipe here is is for
the Manhattan cocktail as you can see
the interesting thing in case you
haven't seen this recipe again this is
1887 that Jerry Thomas bartenders guide
is it is one Pony of rye whiskey which
is one ounce and one wineglass of remove
which is two ounces so it's two parts
removed to one part whiskey which is
pretty much the reverse of any Manhattan
you've ever had in your life unless
you're well actually
so you drink in this bar in which case
you probably encounter to drink like
this in the past it's absolutely
wonderful this way this is absolutely
perfect drink it's much lower octane
than the Manhattans that you're
accustomed to encountering but the
reason I suggest this is a notable step
in the evolution of cocktails is because
it brought a very flavor-packed
ingredient to the equation again an
old-world ingredient the the remote that
they're using here is an Italian of
vermouth the traditional Italian Rosso
which is a little bit sweet a little bit
bitter very herbaceous very full of
character and it marked that kind of
flavorful turning point no longer is the
spirit the main star of the show no
longer is that drink like the cocktail
or like the improved cocktail defined
solely by the spirit at its base now you
have other flavors playing co-starring
roles playing very full roles and really
placing their characters into the DNA of
the cocktail other influences that you
had of course you know I'd mentioned
liqueurs earlier you know the kinds of
sweeteners and the kinds of other
accessories that would factor into into
drinks were things that were readily
available we would not be unfamiliar in
kitchens and bars of the time if you
have a fresh fruit how and and you don't
really have canning technology how do
you preserve it well sugar is one very
efficient way of preserving a fruit
making into preserves with some spirit
excuse me with some fruits such as
raspberries or pineapples you can put
that into syrup form works wonderfully
take all the juice take all the liquid
out of that mix it with sugar filled
preservative power and it works
wonderfully and goes amazing with pretty
much any booze you want to throw at it
some spirits are excuse me some fruits
work better going directly into the
still you can about apricots into a
still make a dry apricot brandy you can
also take those apricots make it into a
liqueur and bring that flavor potential
in the cocktails and as we get into the
later 19th century 1870s 1880s and then
really 1890s oh my god that's when you
really see these herbal occurs like
chartreuse and Benedictine fruit
liqueurs like curry
so apricot liqueur really being embraced
by bartenders and really is sometimes
you'd say liqueur upon liqueur the
drinks are obsessively sweet in some
cases but they have these incredibly
Baroque flavors I mean it's it's
everything is just off this the book
diet that I photograph this from is 1887
they're already out there you know they
have been around for well they have been
in circulation in the United States for
at least a couple of decades I'm trying
to recall the furthest back I can
remember a curse owl recipe coming
around its I wanna say at least 1860 I
know in the first Jerry Thomas geyser
there's curse sound I'm reasonably
certain there's maraschino in there as
well I have to dig back through my brain
a little bit but I'm pretty sure but yes
in in 1887 New York San Francisco
Chicago the major urban centers that
have had these as well as some of the
more happened in smaller towns across
the country
however evolution isn't always orderly
or predictable because as I said you
know the 1890s things were going
gangbusters in terms of cocky LEvolution
we saw a bartender's matching all
different ends of flavors together all
of them kinds of ingredients liqueurs
spirits from from throughout Europe and
the United States and everything seemed
to be you know just setting the stage
for this amazing Renaissance like this
next stage of awakening in terms of
cocktails but then what happens well
three things really you had a world war
Prohibition and then another world war
which is history's little way of
throwing a wrench into everything all of
a sudden our little experimentations in
the cocktail world don't really matter
that much when you know either when it's
totally illegal or when the bars entire
clientele are in the trenches in France
so the first half of the 20th century
was that time of cocktail chaos yes
there were things going on a lot of it
was going on outside of the United
States and places like Cuba during
Prohibition places like Paris places
like London and certainly there's a lot
of creative
a lot of innovation going on in these
stages but in terms of the overall arc
and trajectory of the cocktail the first
half the 20th century was a really
tumultuous time and while advances were
made really it was it was we're waiting
for a resettling and that resettling
didn't really start happening until the
mid 20th century however once that had
happened once that once the war was over
once everybody was trying to get back to
normal if normal is the right word they
can apply to a time when nuclear
Armageddon seemed imminent then several
things had changed within the cocktail
sphere first off those two things that
I'd mentioned earlier that we're not
really part of the earlier equation
vodka all of a sudden vodkas available
not only is vodka available starting
immediately after the Second World War
and heading in the 1950s vodka is like
that you know kind of like oddity you're
behind the bar you know that thing that
somebody comes and says hey did you see
this new thing we just got it's from
Russia and it can try it out on somebody
within decades within roughly 25 years
vodka had passed not only gin but it
passed whiskey they've begun the biggest
selling spirit in the United States
tequila likewise tequila you hardly see
any recipes from before in 1954 tequila
by the 1970s it's picking up steam by
the close of the 20th century the
margarita is the top-selling cocktail in
the United States there's a survey that
was done by a guy named Jack Townsend
who was the president of the New York
bartenders guild in the 1940s 1950s they
did a three-year survey of bartenders
largely in New York but some from around
the country on the top cocktails that
they mix and serve in their bars which
is a fascinating snapshot of what people
were actually drinking 1948 1949 1950
around that time nowhere on that list is
there a margarita the man and then the
martinis there's still it number one and
number two yeah some weird little odd
balls coming in there in a couple of
places like the Dubonnet cocktail you
know how that wound up in the top 50 I
have no idea but nowhere in there is it
something it's awesome but it's top 50
come on but nowhere in there is a
margarita or a vodka cocktail for that
matter by the end of the 20th
these little puppies of the cocktail
world have become the alpha dogs they
were they were driving a lot of what was
going on definitely on the business
point but also in the cocktail point one
other aspect I want to touch on the late
20th century before I bring us up to
what's going on now and that is the food
scientists prior to the Wars prior to
Prohibition aside from the occasional
bit of kerosene in your whiskey most of
the the ingredients you're encountering
from that you were encountering in the
bar were relatively natural if the if a
recipe called for pineapple actual
pineapples went into it or a pineapple
juice or pineapple syrup or something
that can be traced back to a pineapple
same goes for raspberries it largely
became that way after the Second World
War that all changed
you had companies introducing their
cocktail mixes their rapid fixes
imitation flavors imitation ingredients
and really this became a primary factor
not only in the home bars I mean this is
a New York Times article from 1960 sales
booming from mix maker they're referring
to Holland house increase in
entertaining at home proves boon for the
Holland house but also in the bars
themselves you saw a premix sour mix
soda guns things of that nature that
became those kind of shortcuts those
those efficiency measures that really
kind of tamp down the quality of the
drinks that we were encountering
actually one thing I was trying to get a
color photo of this advertisement that I
saw and just could not get it to come
out right it's from The New Yorker in
1959 also for Holland house not the beat
of Holland house too much but come on
they kind of deserve it
it was for a martini mix from Holland
House it said simply add your favorite
gener vodka and you've got a martini
what the hell is in the bottle they
don't even call it remove instead it's
some kind of flavor component flavor
composition that they put together to
sell you instead of removed 4-year
martinis so that was the stage that
brought us up into the 20th century and
to the first stirrings really well of
when I came in ten or twelve years ago
we were starting to see that shift away
from that and towards things like this
evolution is a funny thing
ever since Darwin first floated the idea
evolutionary biology had always been
believed to occur to occur at such a
slow pace you couldn't really observe it
you would have to go back in a deep
history go into the fossil record to
really understand and really witness the
way things change the way that
evolutionary biology changes that's not
necessarily case as was first
demonstrated by David Resnick who was a
student and now a professor at UC
Riverside starting the 1970s and going
in the 1980s and some studies he did in
Trinidad he was studying Guppies you
know the little fish he had when you're
a kid and they would die very quickly
but you know you would always have more
because their Guppies they would just
breed and make more
he studied Guppies in Trinidad and
realized that rapid evolution is
possible we can witness revoluta excuse
me we can witness evolution taking place
in the course of a few generations which
for Guppies is really about four years
folks we live in the age of the bibulous
guppy evolution is taking place at such
an unprecedented level in the cocktail
bar now that we live in a really
remarkable time the we have a boon of
product available availability and
styles we have access to things that
either had been well inaccessible in the
past or even unmade flitt new flavours
new ingredients are coming into our into
our bars
our global transport system can now
accommodate an appetite for French
brandy in China or for Italian Amaury in
San Francisco and really kind of support
that demand and that appetite as it
roams around the world to this growing
diaspora of cocktail bars from San
Francisco to Sydney to Seattle to London
now why is this going on and then also
looking at how is this going to take us
into the future well first off we have
to go
I can look at those patterns from the
past demographic cultural and economic
shifts for example some tastes spread
independently but others need a little
bit of a push I remember in my own
lifetime as a kid a time when salsa was
not in the refrigerator when salsa was
not a word that I knew it was it was
just a flavor that we're completely
unfamiliar with you know the condiments
in my refrigerator and my you know when
I was a kid in the 1970's and early 80's
we're ketchup mayonnaise and mustard
we've seen a shift in a couple of
directions first off culturally in terms
of our tastes for different things there
is a time you know 50 years ago when you
might have taste it's also I thought oh
that's spicy oh that's weird oh my god
that's you know that's a totally alien
thing to me and I want nothing to
whatsoever to do with it we no longer
are like that at least regarding salsa
we you know our culture is shifting in a
way where we are more inclined to
experiment on a culinary basis to
explore the flavors of other of other
cultures but also this kind of dovetails
with this demographic shift in the
United States where we may have seen
things like salsa or to use as a boozy
parallel tequila as these you know
things from from another country things
that are totally alien to us and
everything that we experience in our
home and everything I've experienced in
my life
with the demographic shifts that lead to
a rise in Latino culture in the United
States and it kind of demystifies that
makes it more approachable makes it more
understandable plus it helps that these
things are damn delicious so as we take
away those load there's layers of
mystery and those layers of the alien
and the bizarre we they become much more
approachable and they become part of our
lives and part of our drinking a lot in
terms of tequila we also have economic
changes that are that are at play in
terms of our current cocktail
Renaissance or evolution you know the
cocktail surges at times of economic
booms we have more disposable income to
let go of it's been in bars and
I mean it should also be noted that
drinking surges if not necessarily bar
income surges during periods of economic
decline certainly people drink all the
time it just kind of helps it that our
economic boom from recent years has
helped drive this business in bars also
technologically as I said earlier you
know the the spread of the steamship and
if the Transcontinental Railroad made it
easier to obtain ingredients today it's
it is so easy to obtain information I
don't think the cocktail of Renaissance
would be taking place if it weren't for
the internet or at least not on this
kind of level we're sharing recipes
we're sharing flavor ideas we're sharing
components we're sharing information
about making your own ingredients in the
bars and that's helping to drive this
whole conversation and move things
forward one other thing that's going on
in our drinking culture today and our
drink industry today is the rise of
craft distilling
we've got a tremendous movement craft
distilling roughly let's say if the turn
of the 21st century we had somewhere
between 15 and 20 distilleries operating
in the United States that we're making
all pretty much all of the the booze
that was consumed where there was
produced in the United States in recent
years yes I got two of those guys here's
a little bit better idea of what that
looks like now those 15 distilleries
were largely concentrated in Kentucky
and Tennessee now we have this diaspora
distilling it's spread entirely across
the country it's in almost every state
is it in every state do we have anybody
in Oklahoma now and he distilleries know
Kalama I thought Oklahoma and North
Dakota were like the two last holdouts
I know that there's distilleries in
Alaska and yeah somebody's making ramen
Hawaii yep yep so those are accounted
for this is a better idea I mean we we
went from that 15 at the turn of the
21st century to some estimates range
license and operational to be more than
700 and probably closing in on the four
digit mark within the day that's
foreseeable within the next few years as
[Music]
that's a good question craft distilling
has very much a lot of ways followed
previous trends in the boom of craft
brewing starting in what the 60s 70s 80s
that really got underway and with with
winemaking I mean winemaking is much
more geographically limited but in terms
of numbers of winemakers getting into
the game and participating in it I think
it kind of follows that that in a very
similar way the changes that we've seen
really are legal changes that have made
this possible states have realized that
people yell when you tax them but if you
tax booze and they don't yell quite as
much so it's become an easy accessible
Avenue for economic for free tax income
for state governments and it's you know
as you can see in places like Washington
State I live in Washington we have
passed the hundred distilleries mark
that includes those with licenses not
yet up and operational but or moving
towards that and I think Colorado I know
for a while we're going neck-and-neck
with Colorado we might be right about
the same point and New York oh my god
you know New York is just this cluster
of red pens over here for everything
that's going on there what's going on in
the booze world in these places
everything you have traditional spirits
like gins and vodkas roms being made
with very much with an eye on what is
traditional what is familiar can we take
those things that we've loved for years
and make them just as good you know more
power to them to try that we have the
innovative we have people there's a
distillery in New York who had been
making spirits out of fermented cacao
nibs or cacao beans however whatever the
terminology is you have distilleries in
New York who are making liqueurs based
on traditional Caribbean home
preparations you have you know you have
people who are very much trying to put a
local stamp on it I'm gonna touch on
that a little bit more here in just a
moment I want to get sidetracked on my
own talk but actually yeah no I'm going
to do that speaking
local one of the gyms there we go one of
the gyms we had one of the cocktail
tonight from st. George spirits and
Alameda terroir jeah this is an example
of taking something
uber local and and running with it you
know they wanted a California John
they're using California bay laurel
coastal sage Douglas fir to kind of
produce that kind of aroma and that kind
of flavor that is evocative of Northern
California you're saying you know st.
George does a wonderful job at it
they're there one of many who were
following that similar path whether it's
with Jen or with whiskey worth Brandy's
trying to do something that it's very
much evocative of the local another
example this is Westland distilling in
Seattle this is so much evocative to
local what Westland distilling just
opened their doors a couple of years ago
they've been in operation for a couple
years before that they make only one
thing and that's single malt whiskey
they make it from Washington barley a
lot of these play a lot of craft
distilleries work exclusively with
ingredients grown in their States and
that's you know both for you know and
drinking local reasons but also for tax
reasons plays into it what this is Matt
Hoffman the distillery at Westland what
Matt is holding his Pete there smoking
some other barley using Pete's the
whiskey he's making where the speed is
not yet on the market but we'll be out
of know in a couple of years this beat
is not from Scotland however you're
familiar should be familiar with the
peat smoke whiskies from ila this peat
bog that they dug this from is on the
Olympic Peninsula in Washington State
they found a naturally occurring peat
bog and they're gonna smoke their
Washington barley over it and make
hopefully wonderful Washington whiskey
that has very much that local aspect to
it but plays then that larger familiar
kind of global flavors that we've come
across and the stills I showed you a
couple oh that's that's Westland stills
just so you get an idea of what their
operation looks like so also on the
technological front you know I'd
mentioned how the internet had played
into the to the expansion of the
cocktail Renaissance in the cocktail
revolution other technologies at play in
terms of cocked
themselves we have bars and bark owners
who are reappropriation reappropriation
old technology take something like
barrel-aging which of course is old hat
when it comes to making brandy or making
whiskey and instead applying that to
cocktails you know stick your Negroni in
a barrel come back in three months hey
it's a barrel aged Negroni I'm doing
that with a number of different
cocktails across the spectrum but also
you have bartenders and food scientists
like the good kind that we like who are
playing around with technologies
familiar to other parts of the world you
know whether it's medical technology or
scientific technology and incorporating
that into a cocktail scheme here's one
this is a centrifuge in motion there it
is stop it's clarifying citrus juice I
know we believe you guys do that here
for at least some of your stuff this is
actually at Canon in Seattle that the
photos come from for a clarified lime
juice you know we're at a time now where
the James Beard Award winning book for
drinks this year was liquid intelligence
a book that delves into all different
kinds of aspects relating to
clarification cold distillation use of
liquid nitrogen and cocktails all kinds
of Modernist Cuisine technologies being
brought to the realm of the cocktail bar
so this is where we are now the star of
cocktail creativity has gone supernova
at this point the question now is where
is this going to go you know how was
this how was this gonna play out and
this is where that crystal ball I did
not order on Amazon would it would have
come in handy or maybe not you know
predictions have a tendency to not
become true you know there are
predictions in the 19th century that New
York City would be uninhabitable by the
mid 20th century because it would be
buried in horse manure and as we all
know that didn't happen until the 1970s
or it could be you know you would have
those matters of whimsy you know the
whimsy of fate things like the First
World War a century ago that came along
and said oh you think life is going to
be this way no it's not we're going in
completely different direction you know
last week everybody was talking online
about this mysterious object orbiting a
star 1,500 light-years from here
how it could actually be a Dyson Sphere
you know some kind of array set up by
another civilization other intelligence
another planet so who knows that that
death star could be heading this way in
the in the course of the next century in
which case any predictions I give out
now are gonna be totally crap and then
also there are those things where of
shortsightedness you know the guys who
came up with Bartles and Jaymes wine
coolers I'm sure that they thought that
this was gonna last for decades whereas
all of the things that we do with
cocktails now all the things that we
enjoy so much that we play around with
with so much there could come a time
when the drinking public just goes yeah
it's gone too far I'd rather a beer can
happen it's happened before could happen
again with that in mind with those with
those remarks in mind here's where we
kind of see the trajectory of the
cocktail going best guesses and backed
up with a few facts here and there I
think the cocktail of the future will be
hyper global our increasingly globalized
economy means nothing is off the table
at a time you know in the 19th century
where we saw it as heavy influence
European flavors European ingredients in
the bar
I think the 21st century and heading
towards the 22nd is gonna see flavors
from other parts of the parts of the
world increasingly showing up in the
part we're already seeing that when you
look at ingredients in flavors from
Central America go to any
self-respecting tequila bar in mezcal
bar and you are gonna see flavors and
ingredients that draw heavily on those
cultures and that nation in those
cultures I think South America South
America is really gonna start to come to
shine for a couple of reasons I'll get a
little bit more detail into that but I
think Peru is already kind of pushing
that out there in terms of culinary
approaches and the Pisco culture is
gonna start coming a little bit more
and similarly Asia you know by Joe is
still kind of like one of the you know
by Joe is where vodka was 60 years ago
kind of like that weird oddity behind
the bar the difference is vodka is you
know technically color colorless and
odorless by Joe is not maybe colorless
but he's not odorless not flavorless it
carries a very
kind of gamy character to it so I'm not
sure it will really catch on in that
same way but you know who knows as
demographic shifts come and as ever it's
other things come that could definitely
be on the table also in addition to me
hyper global is if here's the other side
of that paradox
I think cocktail the future of the
future will be hyper local as we're all
already saying we like the example from
st. George spirits
we're from Westland distilling craft
distilling is really a play here and
this is where crab distilling is really
going to be showing up along with the
the influence of restaurant kitchens and
of chefs of looking increasingly local
not only at farms and their immediate
vicinity but at producing that while
growing their own produce I think for a
number of reasons that that direction is
going to continue and so that hyperlocal
aspect in craft distilling in terms of
you know not only working with peat
that's local but but where you'll see
localized Brandy's you know it used to
be you know we're going back to kind of
those old models from early 19th century
distillers in Georgia of where do you
make well you'd make peach brandy
because that was what you grew there I
let you know I live in Washington State
we're starting to see apple brandy
starting to come out some craft from
craft distillers now other parts of the
country you know you're seeing I've seen
cherry spirits from Michigan Apple
grannies from Michigan New York has been
playing with heirloom corn and with
apple varieties as well we're going to
see these localized aspects to the
spirits world starting to come out and
increasingly in circulation and getting
those kind of local touches hyper local
touches into in the spirits also I think
whiskey is gonna be an interesting
category to watch because as we've seen
in Scotland
you have the possibility for this vast
array of similar yet distinct styles
arising in a relatively small geographic
realm in the United States is a much
larger geographic realm and we have
whiskey distilleries operating
everywhere from Washington to Florida
the key factor here is not just the
grain that's going in there although
that is a big thing but also the
maturation whiskey maturation is heavily
influenced by temperature by humidity by
things that range all across the
spectrum from like the guys at Westland
I showed you her age
aging their whiskey in the very wet very
cool environment of the Olympic
Peninsula to garrison brothers in Texas
which is aging his tics his his wet
whiskey in a barn in Texas in the summer
where the temperatures regularly get up
to 120 degrees on his farm so you see
these really diverse influences they're
coming into whisky distilleries all
across the country that's gonna be one
of those places where the hyperlocal
really starts to come out to play I
think also in the local aspect we
received the greater farm connection
we're already seeing stirrings of this
in places like New York State or like
Michigan which I mentioned as an example
of working legally on a legal basis to
open up farm distilling once again
taking back those patterns that we'd
established 200 years ago and
reincorporating them into our
contemporary legal framework so that a
farmer who say you raise apples you
don't so all of your apples you could
sell some for cider but you can also
hang on to some of it and send it to
your neighbor down the road who is
running a still or haven't maybe you
have a farmers co-op still for all of
the the fruit in the area you know very
much like the distillery in Gascony for
making Armagnac having that that kind of
model coming up very small scale but
very localized well that's not just in
the US where you saying that you're
seeing in Germany there's a distiller
that's making a gin with black forest
botanicals which is a hyperlocal kind of
flavor and taste is very kind of Hansel
and Gretel technologically we're also
going to be seeing greater refinement in
terms of the spirits themselves I mean
just as the coffee still added that
layer of finesse of provided
distilleries with a tool where they can
make very clean very pure spirits at a
very high quality in a very high
quantity improvements in distillation
technology today and in the years to
come will give distillers greater tools
for making higher proof spirits things
with greater delicacy greater
and nests I just have much more control
over the process
similarly refinements and cocktail to me
technique or become cheaper and more
widely available things like the you
know the the centrifuge here you know
this is a I think Jamie told me he paid
ten to fifteen thousand dollars for this
piece of equipment so it's definitely
not gonna be in every bar but some piece
of equipment are going to become much
more photo affordable much more
approachable and even if it's not on an
individual bar basis we're starting to
see commissaries you know is for example
in portland oregon there's a place
called obviously the commissary that
functions as a place for bars and for
consumers to go get your citrus juices
your homemade syrups any of a number of
familiar ingredients that come into play
in cocktail bars an individual bar may
not be able to drop ten to fifteen grand
on a centrifuge but a commissary that
serves fifteen or twenty bars in a city
good and can provide this on a bulk
basis so we can see some of these higher
technologies becoming a little bit more
available or a little bit more
accessible and also in terms of the
tools themselves Donley and cocktail
kingdom have been reassessing some of
the historic bar tools that we've used
that really haven't changed in some
cases all that much over the course of a
hundred years and are reassessing them
from a design and from a function
standpoint to make them more usable more
utilitarian for bartenders a couple of
quick things because i'm almost at a
time but they're a couple of big things
those things that happen outside the bar
that are really not a function of what
we do here but that are going to very
much determine and dictate how we drink
and what we drink 100 years from now one
of them is a demographic shift and
population gains census projections for
twenty one hundred estimates that the US
population will be anywhere between
three hundred million which is about
where we are now and 1.2 billion the
mid-range estimate which is like the you
know where they're kind of saying yeah
we're reasonably certain this might be
more likely is around six hundred
million about twice what we are now and
past the half billion threshold
and obviously immigration is part of
that equation and that's going to
continue to influence the types of
things that were exposed to in the types
of flavors and types of ingredients that
we come across but it's also going to
put stresses and strains on things such
as water availability I mean population
overall majesty immigration things like
water availability the cost of raw
materials and and an available cropland
so I got a condensed low because I'm
running over so a couple of things
internationally tequila and mezcal how
much is this going to be a part of our
future obviously you know if we continue
on the trajectory that we've been on
Latino culture and the Latino population
in the United States are going to
continue to increase people obviously
love tequila love mezcal but I have to
say the keel and mezcal are in our
future with an asterisk and the asterisk
is managements tequila is an intensive
monoculture crop it takes a very long
time for the agave to mature eight to
ten years for image for an agave in
which were with that kind of growing
conditions and that kind of lack of
restrictions to to imposing some kind of
genetic diversity or some kind of risk
abatement protocol agave might hit that
kind of speed bump where you see long
massive crop failures and a crop failure
in agave is something that doesn't just
resonate you know for one year like you
know yet a bad year for grapes
okay the wines that year suck the next
year it'll pick up again agave it's
gonna take years for that to be replaced
so the obvious one of those where I see
that with an asterisk brandy is one of
those things you know brandy is largely
a first-world spirit in terms of
production mainly France mainly Spain
mainly the United States where places
where it's just much more expensive to
make that spirit and agricultural inputs
going into it are similarly much more
expensive than any other kind of spirit
out there so while I'm sure that brandy
will always be available I'm not sure
how much it's gonna play a role in their
cocktails at the future and of course
the the big bugbear here
the giant pumpkin in the room is climate
change what is this going to mean not
only in terms of water availability and
ever ability to even live much the way
that we do now what is it going to mean
in terms of population trends
availability of water raw material its
maturation well it's like wine first off
a Conservation International study place
projections from wine were very bad for
much of Europe California South Africa
Australia however you might start seeing
wines and brandies from Sweden
we're from Montana we're from Canada
because that's where the prime grape
growing regions are going to be
migrating according to some climate
change examples that they played through
why in it you know what happens in wine
happens in brandy and the what the grape
varietals that thrive now and places
like France or California may not be the
same grape varietals that thrive hundred
years from now in these much different
places so if we were to do that you know
make your you know save things for for
the drinkers from a century from now to
come back to I think brandy buddy one of
those things to reassess the other thing
is whiskey you know whiskey we're
talking about maturation conditions and
the influence that it has temperature
and humidity play a massive role in your
evaporation and in the flavor of your
whiskey distillers like Buffalo Trace
and Kentucky one of the larger
distilleries in Kentucky created what
they call warehouse X and this is their
experimental aging warehouse in in
Frankfort Kentucky where they can test
whiskey barrels on a number of different
factors to see what kinds of conditions
they react to some of the barrels are
exposed to the elements some of them are
completely in temperature and
humidity-controlled rooms so that we can
try to assess how can we age whisky how
can we keep whisky tasting like the way
it does now even as our global climate
changes so whisky is gonna be another
one those things where it's kind of a
moving target flavor-wise and
composition wise looking into the future
actually that previous slide I just want
to say this is a vineyard in San Juan
teesta it's pop I'm gonna mispronounces
po pollution from Randall gramma Bonnie
Doon this is a massive project he just
launched a Kickstarter maybe six months
ago it's gonna be a huge experiment on
the wine basis to find the kinds of
grapes that will create not only a new
world's style of wine a uniquely
distinctly new world style of wine but
he's also not gonna be using irrigation
gonna be looking at what kinds of grapes
thrive and survive in a drier hotter
climates so that's that's part of the
goal there really the winner I think in
terms of the the booze going into your
glass 100 years it's gonna be sugar cane
sugar cane likes it hot sugar cane likes
it wet likes tropical climates you know
and yeah and there was actually a study
that was presented at a sugar conference
about two years ago that actually showed
sugar Krueger cane yields increasing as
a result of projection they'd done with
climate change so this this could be
something with a range actually expands
matured rum aged rum you know again
you're under the same kinds of
conditions regarding heat humidity in
time so that's gonna be a crapshoot so
really on edge from rum products like
Rome Agra cold from Martinique or Kasasa
from Brazil
Kinshasa might be the thing to keep your
eye on a hundred years from now that
could be something where not only do we
have that kind of thing that's readily
available but sugar cane and rum and by
extension Cocozza are those things that
are that are really readily accessible
they're not alien they're familiar to us
as drinkers we have encountered rum
before we know what they're like it's
not Latino it's not American but somehow
it's a little bit of both and across the
socio-economic lines it's not a poor
person's drink it's not a rich person's
drink like brandy it's something that
goes in all of our glasses so if you're
at a wage or if you're gonna go out and
put futures on something they're gonna
be drinking under hundred years from now
rum and Kasasa is pretty much where
that's going to be so wrapping it up
21:15 what's your bar look like well
it's gonna be a rum bar in all
likelihood you
have lots of other things probably some
hyperlocal things some some things from
around the world but ice might be a
little bit hard to come by but really
your own drinks are gonna be awesome
you'll have some technical aspects you
can use your clarified lime juice from
your centrifuge that you've gone into a
co-op with with the other bar owners but
ultimately you know what I think the the
drinks from a hundred years are gonna
look like pretty much like what you're
drinking now the drinks that we're
drinking now are pretty much like what
people were drinking a hundred years ago
for a simple basic reason some things
just taste good
deliciousness will always win you can
introduce your centrifuge you can
introduce your locally distilled product
from the stuff that you grew up on the
roof if it tastes like crap nobody's
gonna order it certain flavors we will
always love and I think we'll always
come back to those and so in our time
capsule would you put there bourbon
brandy and since I I've literally done
talks and forgotten to mention it I'd
stick my book in there because you need
some ideas from where to go so that's it
undone thank you
[Applause]
[Music]